hello everyone I hope that wasn't too
loud for everyone as some of you were
using the headsets say I'm killing you
with these intros but hope that one was
better as today is the rest day in the
candidates in Berlin I thought it was a
nice opportunity to check out another
game from the Talbot UNIX series so this
is game 8 and in the previous seven
games still managed to win three games
and four games were drawn and even
though tal is leading in this match by
three points tal says that he still
doesn't feel very comfortable he still
feels he's not up to his full form in
this match and he still feels that it's
actually Botvinnik who's dictating the
tone of the battle for the for the
entire match so far and he says that
although being up three points is
basically like you've won the match he
says not really not nothing that's the
player like botanique because it's not
like being up three points in a
tournament in a tournament you can lose
the game maybe someone who is catching
up to you will also lose their game but
in a match if you lose the game it means
your opponent won a game so the hell if
he wins the one or two games the things
can immediately change so here tau and
his second always under Koblenz they
decided to do something crazy they
decided that tal would play a crazy game
in game 8 he will go all out and if he
wins one more game then being up for
points that's basically you won the
match and if he loses one game it's it's
not that terrible so this is game 8
let's see what happens and the botany
already surprises tall from one
he plays d4 so not his usual c4 he plays
d4 which means the gloves are off
I thought can go for any defense he
wants to and Botvinnik is up for a game
so tile goes Knight to f6
we have c4 e6 Knight to f3 botany isn't
interested in the nimzo-indian defense
he employs Knight f3 the so-called
antonyms o Indian and here tall has
talked about b6 go for some Queens
Indian defense go for d5 the Queens
gambit declined but he doesn't want a
passive game he wants he wants to make
things happen so he goes for c5 we have
defy
eeeek after sun d5c capture Sun d5 and
g6 and although I in the database this
is referred to as the benoni tal refers
to this as just a king's indian defense
as he says all of those defenses are
basically Kings Indian defense Knight to
c3 and Bishop to g7 here it all says
that black can go for some immediate
complications would be five and if he
does go b5 he's not afraid of Knight
captures he's a happy to mix things up
straight from the start but the
variation he doesn't want to go into
after b5 is actually e for as he saw one
game that was played like this and he
really liked it for white because after
before white can reply e5 and after a
pawn captures pawn captures there is
this idea that after Queen captures on
f6 white thing go Bishop to g5 and after
Queen to d6 now even play Bishop to c4
so white would get insane development
and after seek after some b2 white can
even just castle and wife is basically
fully developed and black can't even
grab the rook on a1 if he grabs it then
it's all over Queen captures and there
are there's no defense Queen is
threatening to capture the rook on h8
once you move it then rook e1 simply
wins the game Bishop to e7 you simply
capture it and you have to give up the
Queen if you move the Queen then you're
getting checkmated Bishop d6 check King
moves Queen to f6 this is checkmate
so regardless how I mean this game could
play out in a lot of ways but this is
one that also and he didn't like b5
immediately so he plays Bishop to g7 we
have Bishop to g5 and here we have
castles by tau and Botvinnik plays III
and Thal saw that because tau declined
to play this variation with the d6 as
this variation is usually played with d6
instead of this Bishop to g5 move
Botvinnik should have tried and punished
does insolence of not playing d6 by
immediately pushing instead of Bishop to
g5 by immediately pushing efore and now
it's it's a very dangerous
for like for like the castle and E 5 is
coming but okay botanically decided not
to do this botany played Bishop to g5 we
have castles and now III and Thal says
this is a small victory for black but a
victory nevertheless because now white
can't go for the standard setup by
playing efore because now black has rook
to e8 White's King is still in the
center of the board now you can go a
five because of d6 the king is still on
e1 and if you try the standard idea of
bringing this Knight to d2 to defend
this maybe bring it to c4 in the future
then tall wins the game with Knight
captures on e4 and there is basically no
defense against all of the threats point
being that if you capture the Queen then
Knight captures on c3 opens up a
discovered check from the rook you have
to block it now Knight captures Queen
rook captures and after row captures
Bishop from the 8th basically black is
up a whole piece so okay after castles
botany plate III we have rook to e8 and
now Knight to d2 itself says that the
idea of this early rook to e8 the reason
why he didn't play d6 is that he wanted
to do after after a white moves this
night to d2 he wanted to play rook to e5
and he thought that after Bishop to f4
he could simply capture on d5 sacrifice
the exchange and after Knight captures
Knight captures white would either have
to give up another pawn the B to pawn or
he would defend it and then a table
would grab this nice dark square Bishop
on f4 and considering the position to be
fully fully compensated now for the
exchange
but the reason pal didn't do it is
because this rook to e5 he he feared
Bishop to h4 and now after g5 Bishop to
g3 rook captures Sun d5 also given up
the exchange in Knight captures Knight
captures it's not really good for black
it's actually bad for black because now
after night the c4
the white opens up an attack on this
knight on d5 and after Knight to e7
Knight to d6 and this is a this is a
monster position for white
so after Knight
too-tall refrains from going rogue 3:5
he finally plays d6 we have Bishop to e2
we had a 6 preparing b5 botnik stops at
with a 4 Knight B to d7 and now botany
castles we have Queen to c7 with the
idea that of course Stahl wants to unpin
here now this night can move and also he
wants to push c4 at the right moment
here Queen to c2 not going for the
immediate efore although tall consider
z4 to be a better but you know you play
D 3 you don't want to waste another
tempo tempo by playing e4 and here at
top plays Knight to be 6 and this is the
idea of the quote above the board as
tarush says a night is always badly
posted on this we're talking about the
b6 square but tal says that this is
maybe one example where it's actually
not because the knight isn't planning to
stay on b6 for a very long time he just
uses the temple on the d5 pawn at Terra
maneuver it here Bishop to f3
if botanique would now play E 4 then
Thal could actually play Knight captures
on d5 and after he captures Bishop
captures and c3 Queen captures and rook
captures on e2 and it's a perfectly fine
position for black
so after this night to be six Bishop to
f3 which was one of the ideas of Bishop
to e2 and here top plays c4 tall again
considered a move like rook to e5 as
hero like this move but again after
Bishop to f4 attacking the rook rook to
f5 and now Queen to b3 there really is
no reason for that rook to stay there
the Queen defends the d5 pawn nicely
this rook will get will be trapped at
some point and if black decides to play
c4 to kick away the Queen then Queen to
a3 and now it's actually black that's in
trouble so ok after Bishop to f3
tall refrains again from rook 35 he goes
c4 and now botany decides to give up his
dark square Bishop but the group to win
upon Bishop captures on f6 Bishop
captures on f6 and now
a5 simply kicking away the
of the c4 pawn Knight to d7 and now
Knight to e4 attacking tiles bishop on
f6 and nose also now there's a double
attack here on the c4 pawn there's no
way to defend it tau played Bishop to e5
simply preserving the bishop and here
comes Queen captures on c4 offering a
trade of Queens so it's a better mood
than Knight captures on c4 if Knight
captures on c4 then talk and break
through would be 5a captors knife
captures then I can't move
the queen is undefended and c2 this
would be okay for black so Queen
captures on c4 immediately bought tunic
offers the trade of Queens we have Queen
to d8 and the tall says that this is the
position he saw when he decided to give
up the extra pawn queen to a2 by
Botvinnik
and here in this position when the Queen
was still in c4
tal's idea was simply pushing b5 and now
what tunic played Queen 282 he doesn't
want to allow b5 to come with we're a
temple on the Queen and now tile for
some reason doesn't play B 5 B 5 is
again regardless of the fact that the
Queen isn't on c4 after b5 a captures
Knight captures tile makes room for all
of his pieces to get developed and more
importantly this night on b6 is
preventing the night and d2 from
creating a very nice outpost on c4 but
for some reason after botanique played
Queen to e2
tau played f5 and this will prove to be
not so smooth as tal thought it would be
Knight to c3 we have g5 now and here
Botvinnik is isn't afraid of thousand
advancement on the kingside he is simply
preparing to bring this night the c-4
this Knight to a4 and then to b6 and to
completely dominate the Queen side so
Knights the c4 but tal pushes forward g4
as they did agree to this before the
game Bishop to e2 and now Queen to f6
Knight to a4 preparing a night to b6 we
have King to h8 getting the King our
this diagonal that the queen is eyeing
and
so maybe making room for the rockin g8
in the future
g3 h5 and now f4 and tau was very
impressed by this F were moved by
botanique as it immediately requires the
reaction from tau here tall played
Bishop to d4 simply not allowing this
Bishop to be captured because then rook
captures an etude this would be an
extremely active rook
so Queen to a3 now there's a double
attack on the d6 pawn and it all has to
do something here and Botvinnik is also
threatening night to b6 attacking this
rook also this will force tile to
exchange this Knight and tall doesn't
want to exchange this night so tal plays
rook to b8 seems like a passive move but
tall things that it was really necessary
so botanique goes night 8b 6
regardless and here tells us that
botanique had a better move a better
move with the idea of playing he
captures on d4 grabbing the bishop and
simply if rook captures on e2 then rook
a to D 1 first defending the D pawn d4
pawn and after h4 Knights the c3
attacking the rook on e2 and after the
rook moves now Queen captures on d6
Queen captures Knight captures and with
two extra points White's pieces being
blacks piece is not being very
well-developed white would have a great
advantage here but okay both when he has
his own idea of what he's doing he plays
Knight to b6 and we have h 4 here
Botvinnik plays rook a to be 1 again
idea of capturing the bishop on d4 was
possible but now both winning forces it
back Bishop captures pawn captures and
here Knight to c5 by tau G captures on
h4 and here botanique saw that if Queen
captures on h4 then Queen can come to c3
would check after the King moves Queen
can come to e1 and this will be fine for
Botvinnik
so after this G captures on h4 top
played Bishop to d7 and Bishop to d7 is
an okay movie but tau
prefers nicely for simply not and not
allowing both unique to trade Queens but
okay Bishop to d7 and now what tunic
plays Queen to c3 and forces a trade of
Queens Queen captures pawn captures and
here Bishop to b5 this is still a good
move and rook F to e one now defending
the bishop on e2 and if tell captures
the knight and Bishop can capture and e3
pawn is also defended we have Knight to
e4 and here Botvinnik plays rook the c1
a better move was rocked to d4 but he
misses he misses stalls move and here
that actually has a winning game he just
has to play the correct move and in this
position top played worked the c8 which
is the winning move unfortunately for
tal tal played the wrong rook to c8 the
correct move was disrupt the c8 but he
played rugby to c8 and you'll see will
return the disposition to check out why
it doesn't work here tall so that he's
winning the exchange and he immediately
thought that he was winning the game and
it was actually botany who was in time
trouble in this game but tal says for
some reason this quick play by both
Manik affected his play as well so he
played rugby to c8 and now botanique
played Knight to a5 so okay Bishop
captures an e2 rook captures an e2 and
now Knight captures on c3 and now you
can see that tal Wednesday exchanged
whatever botanic place if he doesn't
move the road and simply table will
capture it if he moves a dental will
play Knight to e2 check and pick up the
c1 rook
so Botvinnik save star at all the
trouble he plays rook captures on c3
rook captures on c3 and Knight captures
on b7
here rook captures on e3 and toss says
that this was probably the last chance
for him to play rook to b8 simply kick
away this night and try and win the b6
pawn to maybe hold the draw but he
played rook captures and III he thought
this was still winning but now botanic
simply exchanged and after rook
characters and the knight characters on
d6 you
have you do have a Arab the exchange but
botany has a pest
beep on that's already on b6 and the
past deep on so here top plate rook to
d3 and here the game was adjourned but
when I had had to make one more move for
the game to be adjourned and Botvinnik
studied this position for half an hour
before deciding on what move he will
play tomorrow when the game is adjourned
and feel free to pause this position
find the winning move for both Minnick
and you know check out your your own
endgame skills and don't feel too bad if
you if you don't find the move
immediately after all botanique did
think about it for half an hour so do
pause the video if you'd like to maybe
even come back to it later but ok for
those of you who did find it I mean
congratulations it's really not a simple
move to find and for those of you who
want to enjoy the show here at out
thought that Botvinnik would have to
play b7 and after rook and after pawn to
b7 rook to b3
there really isn't in any way for white
to win this game but unfortunately for
tal botanique played 92 f7 check and
here went all saudis immediately
resigned the game why did he resign were
well a couple of reasons first of all if
you move the team to h7 then simply pawn
to d6 the Knight is guarding the pawn if
you attack the knight and then simply b7
is coming if you try and stop it
then d7 is coming and the rook cannot
stop both passed pawns and on the other
hand after Knight to f7 check it doesn't
matter King to g7 and King to g8 both
lose to the same strategy if you go King
to g7 then b7 is coming you have to
block it rook to b3
now comes Knight to d8 preventing rook
from capturing the b7 pawn and now this
is the idea you have to see after a 5
now tal will start pushing his own pawn
d6 a4 d7 83 now what we could have this
in between check and 96 check and now it
doesn't matter what what black plays if
King to g6 and then simply
Queen comes into the game and after a
couple of checks now you can eat you can
either start to check in the white king
but the white king will always find an
escape and escape all the checks and if
you play a2 then simply h5 and you're
getting checkmated if you capture the
pawn then Queen g5 is checkmate and if
you don't you're getting checkmate it
nevertheless so yeah after this night to
have seven move towel resigned to the
game and game number eight goes to both
Vinick and it's no longer three-point
lead for tile it's two point lead for
now a towel now and the match continues
but like I said we will return to that
famous moment in the game after botany
play this rook to see one move I told
you that rook to see it was winning but
that stout played the wrong rook to c8
headstall played rook eat the c8 then he
would indeed win the game because now
after Knight to a5 now the tall's idea
is working a simply Bishop captures rook
captures and Knight captures on c3 now
there's no point in playing rook
captures on c3 like both eunuch played
in the game because after rook captures
you can't capture the b7 pawn the rook
is protecting it so here you'd have to
play King to f1 simply protecting the
rook and after Knight captures King cap
rook captures with check rook captures
and now you you don't have the
opportunity to capture to be 7 point you
have to capture the night or you'll be
down a piece so King captures and now
rook to c5 is winning you can give up
the b7 pawn Knight captures and now rook
captures on d5 so now you're up the
exchange but white only has the past
beep on at the past beep on D pawn and D
eliminated blacks d6 pawn Bahria instead
of rook if the c8 he played rugby to c8
and unfortunately for tal game 8 goes to
Mikhail Botvinnik
but a well-deserved the game so that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank look you does the
Borg for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
you are one of the first if not the
first contributor to this channel so I
am very pleased you are still enjoying
the content as usual you can check to my
previous videos here
in the in the description below there's
a link to the 1959 candidates tournament
if you are new to this channel or new to
this series so you can check out all the
games that they'll want the wind the
honor of challenging Mikhail Botvinnik
and also there are some very interesting
games there and also there will be a
playlist of all the games I've covered
from the 1960 World Chess Championship
match of tile versus botanique so thank
you all and I will see you soon